[Music]
number one a study comes out that's um
called the serotonin theory of
depression
a system out a systematic umbrella
review of the evidence
came out
and it was uh published in nature looks
like uh and it just explodes goes
bananas and everyone's like oh my gosh
no way huh
and then like most of these things it
makes its way to the popular media press
and the popular media press is desperate
for
one thing
let's not ever forget this in the
popular media press
um when you listen to this show a it's
free and b
um i sell ads like for a mattress
company um i have some supplements that
are coming soon i try to tell you my
book right that's how i make my money
right
so i want you to show up here
um when you're in one of the popular
news media world um
you're selling at you just want eyeballs
and somebody else is dealing with the
ads all right
so your whole job is not to give correct
news
to not to give right answers the whole
job is to get clicks
and the more sensational and wild and
i can make something the more likely i
am to click on it
and
when there's something as complicated as
depression and neurobiology
and
science
and you're trying to push a narrative
that science is all screwed up and no
one should trust scientists and we
should all just sit at home and whatever
um
then this kind of thing comes out and
it's so easy to get all of your ducks in
a row in one fell swoop i can get all
the clicks i want by going oh my gosh
yeah and i can bash science again and
and and so here's that
and then here's my second problem i
refuse to participate in the click bait
so i'm not even going to tell you who
the
pundit is that's running their mouth
about this it's probably not hard to
figure out um because this isn't a
political issue this is a somebody's
talking about something and they don't
know what they're talking about and
they're going to get a lot of people
hurt
and it makes me crazy when people do
this
it makes me crazy like so if you hear me
talk about education for instance i'll
talk about hey teachers you need to let
kids talk in the lunchroom i'm not going
to complain about a problem until i got
a solution to it and now pundits have
taken this study so real quick
it's been 30
plus years if not more decades
where scientists understood
this idea that you get depressed simply
because you are missing a particular
molecule
right and the pharmaceutical industry
absolutely jumped all over this
hypothesis the serotonin myth the
dopamine whatever
whatever missing molecule myth you want
to jump to
and we're going to give you a drug
that replaces that molecule then no
matter what's going on in your life
what's going on in your environment
what's going on is going to suddenly be
solved
and so
ssris selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors right does never has never
added more serotonin to your brain they
don't do that
they
they
manipulate
how that serotonin moves and how it's
bioavailable
in your brain okay
so this idea that you take an ssri to
get more serotonin into your body is
false that's not how that even works
the second thing or the i don't know
what number we're on the 500th thing
here
is scientists have known this for a long
time
the farm industry has continued to push
it that's their deal
scientists have known for a long time
they moved from that to genetics hey we
think there may be a depression gene
there may be an anxiety gene
here's what everybody's come to know the
last 15 20 30 years
that neurobiology matters
and genetics matter environment matters
and personal experiences matter
so i can have 20
light switches in my garage
and all of them turn on a different
light
but if nobody ever turns those lights on
they don't come on
automatically and people think that i've
got all the genes i've got all the light
switches that means everyone's going to
have this that's how that works
right
and you can turn all the light switches
on but if the power to the box is off if
there's a a windstorm outside or it's
raining outside maybe electricity
doesn't come on that day but it comes on
the next day right so environment
matters all this stuff matters that's
why this show is important because we
talk to individual people going through
individual things because that's how you
have to
uh that's how you have to distill it
down that's why in my book on your past
you have to talk about what happened to
you because all that stuff plays a role
here
in addition to your genes in addition to
your diet in addition to how much you
move in addition to
your whatever your
the serotonin and dopamine and all that
stuff in your head here's where i have a
problem
as a
and this is a problem with the media
is that there is no
wisdom
there's just grenades there's just
grenades there's no wisdom just grenades
and so as a scientist if you
look at this umbrella review of the
evidence
that there is no data that suggests that
low levels of serotonin are related to
the development of depression
and also
you look at the bajillions of studies
that suggest ssris help people
with depression
i personally have benefited from ssris
for anxiety and here's why
did it solve my anxiety nope i've been
pretty open about that it doesn't fix
anxiety but it takes the alarm system
and helps turn it down a bit
and quite honestly i don't care about
the neurobiology it worked
so that i could go see a counselor
so that i could have some hard hard
conversations in with my wife in my
marriage so that i could sit with some
parenting coaches so that i could go to
the gym on a regular basis because i
wasn't just pulsing with this
all the time
and so as a scientist you look at this
and you go okay i've got all these ssri
studies that say these things
do have a statistically significant
chance of helping people
and now i just got a new piece of data
that says this by the way is 30 40 years
old it's not new at all it just made its
way to the popular press
huh it's not because of this
well cool
now i've got a new piece of data that
doesn't mean you don't go throw the
whole thing out and it's funny because
i'm not a medicine proponent i am all
about figure out lifestyle and
environmental and trauma
um before you just go take meds i'm
somebody who when i go to my doctor
when i did take a ssri for anxiety i
said before we do this i want to have an
end date on the calendar that you and i
agree on so that i have something to aim
for i don't want this just to be a part
of my life forever and my doctor's
response was you're gonna have to do a
lot of work then like going to
counseling and exercising and changing
your diet all those things
and i was i was up for it i was in
so all that to say is this
if you take ssris
under no circumstances
should you instantly just stop taking
them don't do that
if you uh take benzos benzodiazepines
don't just stop taking them because some
pundit on some news show told you not to
go meet with your doctor
if you are wondering huh i want to learn
more about neurobiology neuro
neuropsychology i want to learn how
these things great there is you now have
the internet you can find all kinds of
studies it's incredible i'll even put a
link to this in the show notes
um
also this is a call to scientist
the more you partner with a
pharmaceutical company the more that you
stand a chance to have your messaging go
sideways
and then this is the result and the
group that looks the worst here is not
the farm industry it's psychiatrists
and i know some psychiatrists and they
are extraordinary people
and they help a lot a lot of people
there's also psychiatrists that are just
idiots like in every job
so what am i saying
number one
everybody relax take a breath
number two
don't go to
a news station
for your
medical needs go talk to your doctor
and that's been a conversation for us
three or four or five years
to my friends who are in the media stop
stop
with the big sensational
because you're gonna get people hurt
you're going to get people hurt because
people are going to watch that and be
like i knew it
worse parents are going to watch that
and say i knew it now my kids are
they're going to get their kids off
there is no well i won't say that i'm
going to say that
and you can tell i'm frustrated i'm
frustrated when people who don't know
what they're talking about run their
mouth about something and they have
influence over a lot of people and
people are going to get hurt
oh man
um
drugs aren't the answer to every problem
they're just simply not
and as a culture and as a country we are
um as a humanity we are well
overdue to reimagine how we live life
and the pace and the scale and the scope
and the maniacal pain all of it
how we do relationships and how we try
to have everything we need look at that
and also to throw out
all medications to drugs
it's insanity it's madness
it's like getting rid of electricity
because of electrical fires